I What is the other option?
>> he's genius.
>> [laughter]
>> This guy This guy is so smart. You're
sitting here like I have the moral high
ground against Destiny. Yep.
>> Jeffrey Epstein has the moral high No,
not quite.
>> [laughter]
>> You know what's great? I actually just
don't believe you.
>> [laughter]
>> Anybody Just be the whole chugay. Just
yell and scream and just cry. Just kind
of write down cry.
>> [music]
>> Uh did you think that
>> Gilded Poo made a video on you and then
deleted it a few hours later?
Oh, wait. Do we get a Do we get an
archive? I would watch that right now.
>> Oh.
Oh, do I have [clears throat] a little
treat for you?
>> [laughter]
>> Here you go. It's awesome. It's awesome.
Destiny promotes deplatforming a
28-minute video.
>> a six It's a premiere archive. So
there's like the six-minute pre-up. You
got Oh, right at the beginning. Okay,
okay. It's a 22-minute video.
>> Apparently he deleted this video shortly
after publishing it. I'm not exactly
sure why. There's a couple things I want
you to know going into this video. First
off, okay, some of the stuff this guy
says in this video about what should be
right and wrong and what he should be
upset about is insane considering he has
a kid that I'm assuming he lives with,
that he cares for.
Um
the second thing is
I might have forgotten the second thing.
All right, let's check this out.
>> claims like doxxing or other claims that
I've seen going around like what?
Organized harassment and some other
stuff. I've not seen sufficient evidence
for that. There's also claims that Nick
Andrews, for example, has lied multiple
times about the contents of what he said
in this Stark server.
Oh, but you know what happened here,
right? I'm already I'm already wise to
it.
Dan basically said, "Hey Star Dust, do
you know some people you could get this
out to?" She probably went to him,
Gilded Poo here with like the whole
narrative she was going to spin.
And this [__] probably just went with
it one-to-one without really checking
any of it. I feel like that's 100% what
happened here. Also, to be clear, I
don't know definitively if she did edit
this. I know she is his editor, so I'm
assuming, but I you know, to be clear, I
don't know 100% if that's
>> have to fire her starters cuz he
couldn't afford to pay her? Was that
what happened?
Uh maybe. I'm not sure.
Uh I've not actually looked into that
any further. I don't know if he actually
lied or not. And personally, I don't
really care because again, there hasn't
been substantial evidence to prove much
of anything on either side. For the most
part, it's
It's literally just fully it like dude,
that's that's actually crazy. Somebody
sent me a collage of like his logs. And
yes, this is like a thing he's doing
where he's like posted a bunch of stuff.
That's what he puts in the video.
Okay. All right, all right, all right.
Cool, cool, cool.
But like, it's not just that. He's
literally said on his stream like live.
Yeah, I do dox people. Yeah, I am going
to dox people. Yeah, of course I do. Of
course I do.
Like it's not
It's so crazy to just start off with no,
there's no evidence to this.
>> It's just been a series of a series of
narratives with very little citing of
evidence thus far. So,
with that said, These are all of the
people against us, by the way. It's just
the dumbest
redneck trailer trash loser people. Just
absolute scum of the earth. Just totally
worthless
who are actually trying to fight us on
this. It's so crazy to watch.
I'm not here to go after them. Now, at
the same time, people might be thinking,
"Are you going to defend Destiny?"
No.
I'm not going to defend Destiny. Destiny
has done several unhinged things
throughout this drama, such as calling
to have people doxxed, trying to get
people demonetized and deplatformed for
This is particularly funny thing. I
honestly forgot this. I By the way, I
got a strike for this on Kick.
I literally got a strike for this
directly on Kick when he called the
report me.
Okay, snarking. All Quimbee can do is
sit there and spam racial slurs at me or
whatever and and complain. Which by the
way, you should
>> [laughter]
>> spam report the [__] out of Kick streams
or whatever the [__] else. The fact that
I'm sitting there with on in Chudlogic's
stream and I think Quimbee called me a
on stream. I think he literally was
calling [laughter] me just like spamming
racial slurs and [__] at me because by
the way, all these guys in the
background of their channels are
>> [laughter]
>> Now, if you guys could believe it, these
guys also use racial slurs in private,
too. It's their Discord all the time.
They ain't just doing it in public, if
you can believe it.
>> [laughter]
>> Always spam reporting all of my and
coordinating spam reporting all of my
100%. Oh, by the way, we didn't even
spam report all of this [__]
It was like I I just only had this stuff
for YouTube. That was it. I didn't go
after Kick cuz I was like I I don't even
know if Kick goes back and looks. It
wasn't worth it, so. In the clip, I
actually go harder. I say that I'm going
to do more than we actually
Like I say we, me and my mods.
Again, nobody I put this like a link to
this stuff in the in the Discord or
whatever, but I this is all me.
If anybody recalls, I did a debate not
that long ago with Stale 2000, where
Stale 2000 was arguing in favor
of mass flagging.
I of course am against it, but on top of
that,
I'm against reporting in general. I
think snitching is cowardly and gay.
Some of us don't want to Dude, this guy
Send this guy to Jacksonville, too, to
the drill rap scene, okay? You guys want
to just escalate infinitely till
somebody gets killed? You. Get the [__]
out of here. No, there's a established
set of rules and all of us want to play
by those rules cuz those rules lead to
the best content. When you have chilling
effects on on menacing people in real
life like evoking the idea of real life
harm against them, when there's a
chilling effect against that, you get
the best speech, you get the most like
some combination of free speech and
control at the same time.
You shouldn't You shouldn't dox people,
you shouldn't invoke or or menace real
world harm.
Obviously, okay?
Unless somebody is posting like I don't
know, child
or some sort of like almost universally
illegal material on a platform, there is
absolutely no reason to report let alone
mass flag. And doing so against people
that you're in drama with
just looks really
gay because it is. And Destiny has done
that from these screenshots I have seen.
The reason I'm bringing all this up
Why is he screaming LIKE THIS?
>> THE REASON I'M SAYING all of this
is because you see
it would be one thing
if it was [snorts] just Destiny
versus a bunch of starkers. That would
be
expected. It's expected that Destiny is
going to do stupid unhinged
Okay? And the worst part about Destiny
is he probably just own it and say yeah,
I'm being petty [__] them, right?
So yeah, that's expected. It's Just sit
back and go it's okay. Why why do why
are you guys making a fuss? Just sit
back, just lay back and go
shut up. Shut stop complaining. expected
that the starkers would go after Destiny
for this. It's this is all
expected.
Here's the problem though, is I had to
retweet stale2000
because he was kind of correct about
something and that is that a lot of
these content creators, the ones that
have complained about Destiny doing this
[__]
are secretly in favor his
mass flagging is based actually take.
What do I mean by that?
Well, here's Justil.
I'm pretty sure I literally said at the
time when he got demonetized, I said, "I
think this guy should be demonetized and
probably banned, but not for this."
And so it probably shouldn't happen
here. I'm pretty sure I said that
publicly. The idea that this is a
private stance is like beyond the
Yeah, I told I told this story
that yeah, oh, I didn't even think to
point that out, but I told the exact
story that we had like an argument about
this and I'm like, "You're right,
probably shouldn't uh
probably shouldn't be called the Charlie
Kirk demonetization cuz I don't want
that done to me. I know that I know
that, but obviously I as I've never once
hidden ever. I don't like Destiny.
I don't like this guy. So.
I was just I was happy that he was
getting with the same way he tries to
with other people a little bit. Um but
but but you're saying in that Discord
they're saying, "Hey, this guy sucks.
Let's all go mass report his ass." Maybe
yeah. If we'll hear about this. Include
all the time I was like pausing here.
I was in trouble when I talked about
this.
>> is telling. Cuz I know the second I
actually talk about this
I'm going to be greenlit to be reported
by everybody's community every stream I
do for the next 3 years.
That's That's why there's a pregnant
pause.
Cuz I know that whatever harassment they
were doing, whatever it was, by the way,
which I wasn't reporting him for.
Uh like any attempts at doxxing,
anything any of the [__] that happens,
okay? I knew it was going to go to 10x
the second I talked about this. And so I
was trying to avoid He keeps going. For
clarity, Destiny is accusing the people
in the snark server that Justil was a
part of
of organizing mass flagging campaigns.
And we get three hums
and silence.
I'll be honest.
I'll be honest
>> remember this ever happening outside of
>> I you forgot.
>> one instance.
I And there might be more.
Like, sorry, more individual. But
there's only one time I've ever
advocated for reporting somebody.
It's Destiny.
And it's for what he's done to me.
Right? It's for his targeted harassment,
his targeted doxing attempts, his
attempts to dox people in my Discord,
okay?
Do you have any idea
how incredibly
that's up? I What is the other option
there?
>> argument.
He's genius. This guy This guy is so
smart.
That is so
and so gay. Why doesn't he call it?
>> is Wait. Wait. This guy is really brave.
Why doesn't he call it? Uh yeah, he's
not at all. He'll definitely call it,
for sure.
Like, honestly
this is one of those people that's so
stupid, I just
Somebody messaged me who was just like,
this guy literally like Basically, it's
just child Like, unless you're posting
child directly to YouTube, he thinks
reporting is wrong no matter what.
And honestly
I'm not even positive on that one, to be
honest with you, based on some of the
other [__] he talks about. What is wrong
with you?
>> [laughter]
>> OH MY GOD!
>> That's That's an explosion you're
causing. As far as I know, this guy only
retains
and not any child
Okay.
It's only There's only
intuition. I have no
clear-cut evidence that this guy is a
It is just every intuition I have.
>> admitted to having a hard drive full of
He's admitted that.
>> he admitted to having a hard drive full
play. Jay Stalk, did you not know this?
The zo sadist stuff? I knew the zo
sadist stuff.
So, he had a hard drive full of uh
and he'd like spam in Discords uh to
troll them.
And then people got upset at this, and
then his response is uh for like
redemption, uh he films himself like
showing the hard drive, he puts it on
like something, and then he shoots at
it. And he's like, "Look, I'm done. I'm
done."
Dude. So,
it's epic. It's epic.
Uh to be fair, that does sound like kind
of funny, but
>> [laughter]
>> I was being
harassed. Oh, dude, why? Why?
I'm so happy they blew us up because I
don't think a lot of people know about
the Peace Go clip.
>> Bringing up like other examples of like
doxing like you or
>> At this point actually I just I don't
care what happens to any of these
communities. Like Peace Go's included. I
think that all you guys are weird and
need to be wiped from the internet. I
think it's all like gotten way
Oh, look at this toady.
Just smiling. Oh, yeah, get rid of Peace
Go, too. Haha.
>> [laughter]
>> out of hand. I'm like at this point I
don't give a [__] about any of it.
Tremble as Hey Spider, are you
>> gotten way too comfortable talking [__]
and being weird and talking harassing
people?
So, it's kind of weird.
It probably gives uh J Soc and his
community more ammo, no? A little bit.
Really? I thought a few people left the
server once people started getting
doxxed. That's what I saw. And now I I
put up the segment today where I can put
that up and walk through like how
Destiny's talking about talking about
doxing, talk about why he's doxing and
who he's doxxed, and how he says these
communities all need to be wiped off the
internet, Peace Go's included. So, I
didn't have that out. I don't think it
was as widespread, but now it's attached
to this and I can get that message out
to more people that Destiny was
basically threatening Peace Go's
community, as well.
He's made.
And again,
>> has said explicitly like, you know, I
will
harass, report everything to just get
rid of you. So, it's like if he's doing
things in that process that are not just
TOS, but actively harmful, what is the
argument against reporting him? There's
none.
Like
Like and just to hurt like communities.
Like he
There's a clip where he's talking about
this and he's literally like gleeful
when he's like he says like, "Well, I
thought I thought a bunch of people left
that community since I started doxing
people there." It's like, dude, I
What else am I supposed to say? You're
trying to hurt somebody else's channel,
somebody else's community by by people
out of that community.
You.
And you're doing it directly yourself.
Like you're sitting here like I have the
moral high ground against Destiny and
then
Yep.
>> Jeffrey Epstein has the moral high No,
not quite.
>> [laughter]
>> I had to just shout for a second, but
It's close now.
>> do. Most people do. [laughter]
You're going to sit here and just
straight up admit you were organizing a
mass flagging campaign. Good way to
thermonuclear blast your own moral high
ground.
Holy
Huh. Why did he delete the video?
Dude, this is so stupid.
>> To be very clear, let me let me explain
real quick my stance on flagging and
reporting.
Um again, this is just to reiterate. I
don't care if somebody doxes me. I don't
care if somebody swats me. I don't give
a almighty if they threaten to come come
to my home. Out of those three things I
listed, two of those things have
happened.
And you know what's really amazing about
that? I didn't Why is your's
my problem? Why is the fact that you
don't care if you get killed or
>> either doxxed or swatted. He doesn't
care that it happens and he has a kid.
Swattings and doxxings are things that
can and have been shown to like lead to
real world harm.
>> passively
and he expects us all to live by his
standard. That's all it is. It's not
like if this was just a thing where it
was harming himself, sure, who cares?
But like he's caring for a kid. Like
this is deranged when you're like a
father caring for a child, is it not? I
I mean, you could just say you don't
report no matter what, but then how do
you stop people from doing this to you?
The only way you do that is by basically
engaging in the same tactics.
It's So, I I don't know. Or or
escalating past that, right? He
literally he literally is not even
attempting to make any kind of argument.
He's just like, you know, knows he wants
to go after you, so he's just made a
video on it.
I just let yourself get
Why? Yep, just lay down and die. Just
you lay down and die? Just lay down Just
lay down and die for me.
them. I did not ask people to report
them and I didn't even block them
because it's cowardly and it's made and
it's cringe. Why on earth would you do
that? It's so
And beyond that point
to make this even Beyond the point that
you're gay cuz I don't like you. Further
from that point
>> more clear.
This violates like the number one rule
of getting doxxed. You shut the [__] up
and you don't [__] acknowledge it.
What do you think flagging it down does?
Oh yeah, it tells them they were right.
I didn't flag him when he attempted to
dox me.
So so just keep letting him dox more and
more people and never do anything about
it then. That's That's really smart,
actually. When When I was the only
person, I did not flag this guy at all.
I was the only person Well, when I was
one of a very small handful of people
targeted, which was only a little while,
I didn't flag this guy.
It was when he went after my community
explicitly for it.
>> is it? You got to go on stream, man. I
actually can't deal with this guilded
poop. Loser hiding like a all the time,
man.
It's very sad. It's very sad.
And if you flag Destiny down after he is
he is doxxed you and you've gotten rid
of all of his platforms like you appear
to have wanted
what do you think happens then? You
think the harassment stops? You think it
just comes to an end?
No, I just don't want him to make money
for it. That's basically it.
I I understand that he's a totally
deranged psycho and he's going to keep
doing whatever he's going to do for as
long as he can possibly do it.
I just don't want him to make money
while doing it.
While trying to like actively destroy
people I enjoy watching.
>> just like, you know, let's say let's say
he loses YouTube and he's really good at
just a gig. Well, maybe he would
you know, not want to throw that away.
Possibly. Yeah.
After you've cu- Like the TOS is your
legal code and your legal system, right?
Like
>> Because what's his what's his other
option? His other option is setting up
his own CDN and streaming directly on D
D J. That's his other option and then he
has no uh
I mean like I don't I don't think I
don't think you get paid from
uh from posting on Rumble. And he's got
it all Oh wait. Oh wait. No, I forgot he
over the CEO of Rumble.
>> Oh yes, [laughter] dude. Oh yeah. So he
wouldn't be getting paid. He might be
able to stream there, but he he wouldn't
be getting paid. I forgot the Rumble CEO
hates him.
>> Confirmed that the doxing information
was correct.
Are you insane?
Do you not understand how crazy people
work? Dude, I'm I feel like I'm so as a
content creator. I can't be 1 1,000th
this confident without knowing the
facts. Like that the clip he's reacting
to
>> as well and like yeah, I bet this guy
will let you just get on just say the
most
you've ever heard. It's like wow, you
like actually think that. You're like
the dumbest
Uh it's so Yeah. I I have like such a
high bar for when I want to take a
strong position. Like such that I
sometimes won't take a strong position
on something when it's like good to do
it for content. Because I've like I
haven't looked into this enough. I just
I can't do it. I can't put myself out
there like that. And then there's like
this who haven't thought about it at all
and they're just like yeah. Hey, you're
gay if you don't agree with me.
Incredible.
But can make no mistake. Make no
mistake, Destiny's crazy. What do you
What do you think Destiny's going to do
in the wake of that? Have you thought at
all through any of this? So
I also that's pretty much precisely why
I wasn't doing it publicly at all. So
no, this is really stupid. This is
really dumb. And my take on this is so
black and
>> out about you on Twitter.
Yeah, I know. I I asked him at some
point. I was like hey, what's your
actual problem? I think I I even
remember what he said. I covered it
earlier today. I can't He's so
forgettable. I cannot remember what he
said at all. I don't even want people
flagging people on my behalf. So, yeah.
Anyway. So, I will cop to that. That I
absolutely It would have been
I don't remember what it was. But, I
will cop to Yeah, I totally tried to
report Destiny for what he's done to me
and people around me. Is there somebody
we've mass reported? Is there somebody
Well, I don't even remember what I said
in that server. But, I definitely
around the time of like the e-sports
Battle and Wicked Supreme stuff. Yeah,
it was like, "Okay, the we're we're mass
we're reporting this guy. This loser."
mentioned on stream before. I've kind of
tried to go out of my way never to
mention it on stream cuz Yeah, I wonder
why. a total psycho who already has a
vendetta. I don't want to incur like
more of a vendetta. I don't even know
what that looks like at this point. BUT,
HEY.
I don't want to get mass reporting back.
Really?
It's It's It's almost like that's the
consequence of mass reporting people in
the first place. Sorry. He's confused.
Destiny deserves it and you don't. I
mean, obviously, but
I
>> [sighs]
>> I
I don't know. Like, there's there's a
big difference between just mass
reporting someone you don't like and
then mass reporting someone who's
causing like actual tangible harm. Yeah,
this is so obviously the argument is
obvious. There is an active harm being
committed.
It's a serious active harm and it's
against YouTube TOS.
Therefore,
it should be reported.
That I thought The argument is literally
that simple. What is the argument
against J Stokes who's causing an active
uh
serious harm?
That's the consequence of mass reporting
people. It's almost like this is kind of
what happens whenever you go full
and start mass reporting people. Like, I
don't want I don't I don't want to to I
don't want to shoot this person. I don't
want to shoot at this person because
they might shoot at me back.
Because they will mass report with
You see somebody in alley and they're
like someone. You've got a gun. You're
like, "Hey, stop." And
apparently it's not like
>> is bad. Don't don't say anything. Just
walk in.
>> Why would you try to stop this from
happening? He might shoot back at you.
Are you shocked that he'd shoot back at
you?
With no actual impetus. It was when he
used his his platform, DGG, right? The
destiny.gg website. In other words, they
bad, us good. Yes, yes, we got it. Yeah.
to
Uh very technically.
I will say I also reference this cuz I
was watching this and I was like kind of
like, uh
Should I talk about what he's talking
about? Cuz I know I know what he's upset
about right now.
I was like, "Should I talk about it?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I don't I don't mind
making this public." Like they're going
to make it public and try to make a big
story out of it. I'll just explain what
happened cuz I'm totally justified in
calling for this.
And but what I should do is I
what I tried to do today was put it
together a little bit more, like
precisely what it was about.
Pretty rough. Dox multiple people in my
community. That site is linked to his
YouTube. When you have a site where
you're engaging in TOS activity, right?
And And sorry,
in against community guidelines
activity, there's a policy that says if
you link to that on your YouTube page
and you engage in TOS breaking policies
over there or TOS breaking behaviors
over there,
you can be banned.
So, not only were they trying to report
Destiny for doxxing, but it wasn't even
doxxing on the platform that they were
reporting the [__] for. No, he was just
calling for people's deaths on on the
platform. Oh, yeah, he was also Yeah.
And the the the people he was doxxing
specifically. He was, yeah, he was. They
were go using some very specific verbage
in the TOS to justify.
This is so
>> verbage. The verbage right says, uh you
can't link to TOS breaking content.
Well, that's really specific, bro. Yep.
Yep. Mate, bro. Like what the [__]
right? Like it's just gay. This is gay.
What is wrong with you? Like I can't
imagine hating some
Again, this is a 40-year-old man who
cannot form a actual argument. It's
crazy.
>> No coherent thought. Like, and
it's like so obvious cuz if he if he
thinks you can report child porn on
YouTube, if somebody had a really
popular YouTube page and they linked
directly to a site with child porn on
it, you think they should just be
allowed to stay on the platform? You're
just like, "Yeah, keep that guy there."
Still on the platform. Still on the
platform. Okay, bro.
>> platform. Somebody so much that I'm
fishing around through the TOS
desperately trying to find something to
go after
Uh by the way, uh for about 6 months,
people were desperately linking me this
TOS page going, "Report this guy. Report
this guy. Report this guy. Report this
guy. Report this guy. Report this guy.
Right now, report this guy."
I was like, "Uh
kind of he's kind of not doing it
anymore and I like I I'm super against
reporting.
It was specifically and I say the
problem is at the beginning of this clip
I say, "Oh, for things he's done to me."
It's really and this is just fully born
out in the logs is because of him going
after Esports Batman and threatening
Peace Go. for them for
>> it's like, you know,
it's one thing
yeah, to get doc streams on you, but you
can you can keep going with doc streams
on you, you know? Like, it's not it's
not the end of the world. If someone's
going to literally try to just ruin your
community by doing harm to people within
your community so that people are
chilled from
from every interaction with your
content.
And yeah, I'm sorry. That's like
literally this is like, you know,
I don't know what What what would they
call that? There's like some uh is it
like
if it was like a lawsuit, it would be
like tortious interference or something
like that, right? You're like
deliberately maliciously
interfering with someone's business in a
way that isn't um allowed in the market.
So, Yep. Yep.
Yep. It's like
yeah, but It's like not even remotely
close to like something that's
objectionable. And everybody understands
that. I really can't that black hat
person I'll I'll I'll up the tweet and
then I'll Dude, you know what? Dude,
Destiny says that if someone slashes
your tires on the way to work, you can
shoot them.
Destiny's slashing your tires. You're
You're only reporting him. So, this
seems perfectly within Destiny's I mean
not only that but I'll just point out
once again, he had it already on stream,
but one second second one second one
second. He He already had it Guild of
Pooh already had it on stream, but if
anyone can find J Star calling me an F
slur on his Kick stream, send me the
clip and I will report him to the Kick
Partner Program as well.
I got a strike for this by the way on
Kick.
Like
Like he's just straight up in his chat
doing the
same thing. I'm going to report this
guy. We should report this guy. But like
honestly just to begin with, he's
already somebody who does this, but
again, didn't even didn't even try to go
back at him for it.
You know, we do we do take the uh
slings and arrows sometimes.
But that's cuz he was doxxing members of
my community just for having normal
conversations. Just for having normal
conversations.
>> Just for having normal conversations.
Yes. You know what's great? I actually
just don't believe you.
>> [laughter]
>> Anybody who ever That's That's like
whenever a cop
>> stuff.
Awesome video.
I Dude, I wish I wish I wish I was
joking. I wish he wasn't this like
totally unstable and like losing his
mind.
I'm not even joking. Like I wish this
was not the case.
Maybe we had a couple beers. Like that
that's what that was. Um so no, I I I
don't take it on face value. W W
alcoholism analogy? Do you what you just
said? Now granted I am not saying for
the record that he or any of the members
of his community deserve to be doxxed.
Obviously not. Obviously that is
astronomically unhinged for Destiny to
do. Okay?
That is absolutely [__]
>> word instead of just saying something's
wrong or bad. It's always like oh,
that's unhinged. That's deranged. That's
>> Well, because let's try with with a lot
of people like Diorio, I can tell that
doing it deliberately. This guy
literally has not formed an argument. He
doesn't have an actual opinion on this.
He is a dented idiot. And he could never
defend any of this in any conversation
cuz he's just a [__]
the logs he posted. So, this isn't like
directly when he did it. This is like a
couple days before he started doxxing
people in the Discord. These are the
logs. I would say repeated unwanted
contact or harassment is some kind of
like showing some of it. By the way,
but it's certainly still a form of
harassment. I'm sure they're talking
about the cyber stuff. At the end of the
day, Cyper is still basically the only
person I'm aware of that has done
anything at all on behalf of Rose's
well-being. If all he sent was a single
email to those people with that concern
in mind, I don't think it qualifies as
harassment. But like you said, highly
inappropriate IMO.
He shouldn't have done it. By the way,
this is what Destiny says is cheering
Cyper on. That was the reasoning he
used. This is cheering Cyper on. Like, I
don't think it qualifies as harassment,
but like you said, highly inappropriate.
Is apparently the everybody's cheering
where a whole bunch of people are
are basically arguing this stuff and a
bunch of them are basically totally
against Cyper contacting at all in the
first place.
All all subject to some reasonableness
standard. I don't think cold emailing
someone and their family is enough to
constitute harassment. Now, if they told
that told him to stop and he continued
to do so, then we're talking.
It's engaging in a course of
uninvited unwanted conduct that would be
annoying or alarming. It does not have a
legitimate purpose as well or
well-rounded definition. But that's not
necessarily kind of against anything
else. It doesn't have to be repeated to
be harassment. Your first message to
someone can be harassment if it's a part
of a greater campaign. That's why I
chose the word perpetuating.
The guy to
This is what he's crashing out about.
Also, That was tough really.
Destiny's like fighting directly with
Cyper on Twitter today. I saw that
earlier, yeah.
>> Cyper was like I think Cyper is like
kind of owning him, too, which is very
funny. I saw Cyper's tweet is like, he
unblocked me to tweet this and then
reblocked me. So, I'm just I'm just
going to point out how this is wrong.
Dude, all these people out here just
making enemies out of autism. I don't I
don't know why you do it, dude. Like
these people can be these people can be
annoying to you way longer than
way longer than you'd expect if you just
lash out at them and attack them. You
got to stop.
Destiny and Dan. However,
however, the response is to
either say nothing,
which is probably the best option,
actually.
Um or if you just can't keep your mouth
shut, point and laugh. But what you
don't do is
that. So, all you've done is just told
everybody who got or told the person
that did the doxing that every single
person they doxed, they were absolutely
correct about. You just went out there
>> how that works.
Dude, this guy is so stupid. That's
That's true when it's an individual
instance and you're the one being doxed
and you talk about it in a way that
confirms it. That's not true when he's
doxed a broad swathe of people
and you don't necessarily even know that
they're all accurate, you know? That
That's not That doesn't follow.
He's literally just arguing that he's
like psyched that there's a chilling
effect on the discourse.
Yeah, it's
it's crazy. I also
the doxing says it's me is from like
March and the reporting is from months
and months and months later.
This argument wouldn't This argument
wouldn't even work. a dox. This is
profound levels of idiotic.
that I shouldn't report him for those
things or that it would be bad or if he
wants to come out and talk about it at
all,
go ahead.
Dude, why is he his hand over his face
like he's Oh, he's got a cigarette. I
was going to say, why is he pretending
he's thinking? There ain't nothing going
on up there.
>> Yeah, I just explained it. So, what's
great is is it gets worse. Oh, this is
the one. Yeah.
It gets worse, somehow. So,
here's yet another clip.
He's suing, I think. Uh I think what's
going to happen
Someone talks to me is wanting to be
called for the people to come to my
home. I still wouldn't report them
because that
made and cringe. Okay, dude.
>> [laughter]
>> No wonder No wonder he's out here so
That is like literally that is an
obvious justified instance of reporting
at the best of times.
And you're saying you you still won't do
it even for a petty kid. Okay, well,
enjoy being the most man alive, I guess.
of this guy admitting multiple times to
doxing all these people. He makes up
that I've had some hand in it or I've
done something back to him or that
something like untoward has happened
because of me.
Literally no evidence no literally no
evidence of it. He's going to keep doing
it. I don't think it's healthy to have
him on these platforms and to advocate
for doxing more people on these
platforms. I do think he should be
banned. I think he should be
demonetized. I don't think he should be
doing this with like I don't think he
should have a platform where he's making
money.
Dude.
And now
he's just straight up saying it.
Yeah.
>> saying it. He is just saying that he
wants
to go after Destiny.
>> it out.
Bunny.
Guy goes to three blue one brown and
he's like, "This guy is saying that
addition is commutative and transitive?
He's just saying it." It's like, "Yes.
Yep, he's just saying true facts about
the world. Yep, 100%."
>> out and said it.
This is some cringe like uh visual anti
I think this is gay.
[__]
Uh it makes me think that all this is
all about is simping over a woman. That
is actually the only way any of this
makes sense, by the way, is oh my god, a
got revenge.
We must go and fight for her honor.
Which
This is [__] embarrassing, man.
It's interesting because this is a a
pattern that's been revealed. Actually,
there's a really funny clip I'll show
you here in a minute that somewhat
proves that point. But but yeah, like
it's it's this is all really really
really really really stupid. This is
really stupid. This does not make you
look good in any way, shape, or form.
I think that's why you did it was just
to look cool.
To Yeah, to look very cool. That's why I
you know
definitely called for this type of
publicly multiple times. I think that
basically nobody saw this this clip I
know I know that she clipped it that she
watched this stream but she didn't post
this clip and I didn't go and what I
didn't go to kick or anything like that
but
I I did it hoping that eventually
Destiny would have a mole in that
Discord and that it would come out.
there and say well Destiny isn't good
either.
But Destiny being bad doesn't make you
look good. off of this.
It's actually pretty over. Kicks out the
exemplars of morality. I'm pretty sure
they're still pretty badly against
doxxing. Does he play video games
question?
Well, he knows he's going to get owned.
He's implying that he's going to sue I
guess. Oh [__] I don't No, I I think
probably just going after the platforms
is the good choice. I think I think
YouTube given what has already happened
to him on YouTube would consider
terminating him over this. Bro.
>> 100% right? I never By the way, don't
want anybody to make anything up. Just
want to take the explicit admissions of
guilty conduct, right?
And just say yeah, I think I think this
YouTube channel is YouTube.
>> Slimy bro. They do I okay.
>> May maybe I've got just like no
commentary to add. Just like just say
just saying just saying [__]
just so slimy bro. Wait what what
exactly?
He should just get a soundboard, right?
Like if he was hitting like the fuzz and
Fuzz fuzz
>> hitting the crashes. Yeah,
way better way better. Great off
platform stuff. Good for him. That was
the implication.
It's slimy. Like you can't say this [__]
and not look like a
This looks wow. And I know there's a lot
of people defending him.
>> which is coming across almost like an
academic paper, frankly. Basically like
Socrates, I think. This guy
>> Yeah, I feel I'm being enlightened right
now. around saying, "Oh, no, he's a
>> Oh, I don't know anything. You're gay.
You're good gay.
Okay, why? You want to be dogxed? Okay.
When somebody tries to swat me and my
child, I just like I'm just going to use
my kids as meat shield. I'm just going
to use my
kids as a meat shield against the
feds.
I think something
>> TOS and blah blah blah blah blah. I
don't care. I actually just don't give a
Okay? Like, yeah, it's bad. Yeah,
Destiny bad. You don't need a whole lot
of to convince me of that. However,
to respond
It's honestly like he doesn't need to be
convinced Destiny's bad. Can I convince
you in some way that your child's life
is worth protecting? I'm not sure I
could, but I would like to try. Could we
have a talk? Would you come on the
stream, Gilded Poo? I just like to try
to convince you that your child's life
is
>> life is worth protecting. What? What if
moving your cursor from one side of the
monitor
into the middle, clicking a few buttons,
filling out a text field, clicking
another button to try and, you know,
protect your child a little bit? I think
so. Maybe that by just trying to
deplatform or trying to mass flag him is
just gay.
Um I'm going to assume I'm going to make
the assumption that Nick Andros probably
didn't do anything that bad. That Shimo
probably didn't do anything that bad.
He He He agrees with like He agrees with
like my perspective, but like I want to
reject it anyway because I know he
doesn't know enough to say that.
Yeah, like I'm just like, dude, I'm
going to kind of assume that it's like,
dude, you the facts are there. Just go
watch the debate that happened.
>> into it. You
Just try to interpret more than
a one piece of information for a video.
It's crazy. Until there's some
substantial evidence to prove otherwise.
And
He's drunk, right? I don't know if it's
really drunk or more just like uh what
would the word be?
>> dented. He's just totally dented.
>> Well, he is dented. But like he's a
functional alcoholic. So like I I'm sure
this is just his like baseline. He's
probably not drunk. He's probably
>> Do we know this guy's an alcoholic, bro?
I'm Wait.
>> Uh yeah. So he is
an alcoholic. Do you not Do you remember
the story where he um
he got like blackout drunk one day, took
a bunch of pictures of his sent it to a
bunch of women, and then woke up?
And then uh when he that um that fat
black girl, he said that the only reason
he did that was because uh he had a
weekend alone without his kid, and he
wanted to
>> [laughter]
>> get drunk. So he got blackout drunk
again,
and then completely forgot about it.
Aside from that,
in a nutshell though, their
justification for that I think is gay. I
I think it's gay. I think it's gay.
Visual anti-cringe. And this is it. Like
you're putting in Dan, Dan, let me ask
you this. Dan, let me ask you this. Is
Tecto Is Tecto incredibly accused of
being a with a protective order?
Oh, um I think so. Is that true? Okay.
So would it be logical to make sure
Tecto isn't violating his order and
harassing his victim?
Now, Dan is going to say this. This is
like one of the few things he said on
this stream
uh that wasn't like annoying and gay. Um
but he's going to say something that's
absolutely correct.
>> This guy has such well-formed thoughts.
That's what I'm noticing here is this
guy really has some well-formed,
well-articulated thoughts that he
delivers just perfectly. Everybody I
don't like and all of their actions are
gay. It's all gay.
I see where this guy never leaves the
the
watchful eye of Lylo Convoy and that
gaggle of disabled adults.
It's crazy.
No, Shamuel. It's not your business.
It's not your
It's not your problem.
>> I think every time Go to Poo opens his
mouth,
I think significantly worse of Beckett.
And frankly, I I didn't know that was
possible.
Well,
you just needed to take a shot at
Beckett, didn't you?
You know Beckett like loves you, right?
You know Beckett loves you.
>> about taking shots at Beckett. No, I do
I do
>> just hit Beckett in the face. Beckett
literally loves you. You're one of his
closest friends. You
just punch him in the face
so many times every single day. It's
wild to watch. It's the most abusive
relationship I've ever seen. Play nice.
Not only is Beckett
a people pleaser,
um
which is what you're actually describing
there. Which is one of the most
despicable things you can be, frankly.
As much as I love Beckett, that is like
literally like one of the most annoying
things you can be in in life. Uh is a
total people people pleaser, which
Beckett is. He tries to just tell me
what I want to hear when I'm talking to
him. He tries to just get out of things
and try to stay out of stuff, which is
very lame. Um
The fact that he will play nice with
people like this, the fact Anyone that
like has super disabled people like this
around them, who have severe substance
abuse issues, just like the horrendous
going on can't take a single thought,
and they don't say anything about it,
they don't just rip this person apart, I
think incredibly poorly of them. If If
someone's not doing that, I think very
low of them.
I mean,
I understand what you're saying. I don't
think rip them apart I feel like if
you're not going to
It needs to be firm. You need to be firm
in dealing with them, right? You can't
Like people like this
basically like
they like seek out people like Beckett,
who are people pleasers, who won't give
them the the advice or the
I guess talking to or the
>> to they need. The the Hey, look, um like
every video you've ever put out is like
kind of terrible. And you're really bad
at articulating your thoughts, if you
have any going on in the first place.
Who gives a [__] It's a whole lot of
other people's business, a whole lot of
other people's drama. I don't know why
you're digging your
nose into it. Who gives a [__]
Oh, and an anti-semite, too. I'll be
telling the ADL about that. Dan Soloman,
hello?
>> [laughter]
>> Hold on, he's not talking He's not
talking about Dan. I do think he's Is he
thinking about you or something here?
Cuz he's talking about Shamoo. And
Shamoo's shy. Yeah, yeah. Well, maybe
he's just going Maybe it's cuz people
call Shamoo Sham Jew. He's thinking of
that. Oh, maybe.
Do people call him that? Okay, awesome.
This is visual anti-simping to the max.
Is he trying to say vigilante? I'm I'm
so Vigilante, yeah. Vigilante. If people
say it with an E at the end.
You know what I'm saying? Why would you
do this?
And then think it makes you look good.
Oh, for you? No. You're not the police.
You don't have a PI license. You're not
allowed to be going out and like like
looking up people's
and data breaches. So, this If this
person You say this was the only
thing Dan said?
Yes.
That's the most talking Dan said in the
entire conversation. I know.
[clears throat]
These guys who like sucked off Turkey
Tom and Willy Mac All of the people who
do any amount of research. Well, they
don't do the research, but obviously
their researchers would use tools like
this, right? Yeah, but it's not even not
even that, though. It's like what Dan's
saying like about it being illegal and
[__]
It's It's not illegal to to view data
breaches in most of the US as far as I
understand, if any of it.
Fair.
I didn't hear him say it was illegal. I
thought he said he's basically saying
you're not allowed to go and look. No,
he said he said it's illegal. You don't
have a PI license.
look good.
Oh, for you? No. You're not the police.
You don't have a PI license. You're not
allowed to be going out and
like looking up people's and data
breaches.
>> So, this If this person is leaking
documents Yeah, I don't think he said
illegal. I think he said you're not
allowed. Maybe you could have inferred
illegal there or maybe
>> sure that was something previously that
that
pretty heavily loads the law implication
in there.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure illegal was said at some
point in that conversation. I do think
somebody asked if Dan has a PI license.
That was my assumption was like Dan's
probably told me on stream at some point
that he's got a PI license or something.
I'm guessing he does and that's why he
thinks he's allowed to do it and nobody
else is. Cuz Dan's all in all of you I
wouldn't be shocked if Dan had whatever
the highest tier that tool is. I
wouldn't be shocked if he had it.
Right? Dan does this stuff all the time.
For fun. Dan will do it for fun.
Like without without the goal of
harassing somebody without the goal of
like telling them he did it. He will
just look
>> their name into a little service to have
a little peruse while he's sitting
there, you know.
I feel like he'll pour himself a drink,
sit down one night and be like, "Hey,
here's somebody who just came on stream.
I wonder what I can find about them." I
fully believe he knows that.
>> of glass of whiskey or wine or
something, handful of Ambien, fistful of
Ambien.
>> [laughter]
>> Sit sit down at his desk. What's Nick
Andrews' first name? I shouldn't say
anything about I should just like,
"Okay, yeah, just let them." Protector?
No, you're not the you don't have a
license to do this. It's against the law
for you to do that.
>> if it's it Ooh, there it is. It's
against the law for you to do it. Yeah,
yeah. There you go. That's definitely
not true.
>> You added it.
Yeah, so that is not true at all and
they go to prove saying that's the only
good thing Dan said in this entire
conversation. Nice one, you [__]
idiot. It's against the law.
>> No. Are you kidding me? Wait, why is it
that this guy is a private
and he's leaking court documents and
harassing me.
That's actually And the police said [__]
Then Wait, wait, just give me Nobody
Nobody in that sub
So, yeah.
Um
It's really gay.
This is all over a woman.
In every single instance. Why are we
doing
>> insightful.
I don't I just don't
>> on weird crusades like every woman is
Helen of Troy.
What what's wrong with you? What why are
you doing this?
Dude, I I just can't I I can't I can't
understand. I refuse to understand
actually. And on top of all of that
you know, I don't know this as I said I
don't know the specificities
of what I'm about to mention, okay, the
the absolute specificities of it all,
okay? I think
>> dissolved in my head.
>> that having a Discord server Oh, never
mind.
>> that sole purpose is to monitor
specific YouTubers is cringe.
It's not the sole purpose.
Clipping Discord is the it's literally
for clipping.
Clipping and archiving. Clipping and
archiving. So, a general content
creation. I'd say the archiving is in
service of the yeah, clipping and yeah,
exactly. I I I don't Yeah, like
realistically supporting a set of
content creators is really what it's
about, right? The clipping and the
archiving.
>> a resource pooling.
You know, user, you know,
what what would you say? It's like the
sweatshop. It's a sweatshop.
In of itself, irrelevant to all the
other pedantic details, irrelevant to
whether or not there was doxxing,
whether or not there was organizing
harassment campaigns, whether or not
there was organizing a mass flagging,
ignoring all those details, let's assume
they're all false narrative claims.
The mere act of having a Discord server
that sole goal is to monitor If he says
it's gay, I'm going to actually I'm I'm
messaging him right now to hop on the
stream.
>> Yeah. The day in the life of X number of
YouTubers on this on a very specific
side of the
EHD drama fence
is absolute absolute peak
cringe.
That's cringe and gay. Dude, it's like
all of these words mean nothing.
>> all this is gay, this is cringe. It's
man like all there's nothing. You're
saying nothing. I would say it's gay to
pretend you have an argument when you
just don't like the people. Just fire up
your stream and go, "I really hate these
guys." Just be the whole picture gay.
Don't pretend you have an argument. Just
say, "I hate everything these guys do.
It's all gay and cringe." Go on your
stream and just cry. Just gather right
down crying. If this is what you
[laughter] want to
just fire up your stream
and cry for me, okay? Because that's all
I'm hearing right now. [laughter]
That's what you do.
And yet all these content creators were
just
this obsessed.
I'm going to be I'm going to be very
honest with you.
Uh that's one thing we'll never deny,
okay? Yep. Extremely obsessed.
>> I'm obsessed. Totally obsessed.
None of this matters. None of this
matters. None of this is actually
world-ending levels of importance.
And if you want to end up where this guy
is in life at the
>> two things actually. Wait.
>> Yes. Dude, nothing
>> doesn't doesn't matter or world-ending.
Wait, those are actually the It's a
binary actually. I don't know this. Uh
>> It's either going to end the world or it
doesn't matter.
Dude, it's If you want to end up where
this guy is in life at the age that he's
at, have this attitude about everything,
okay? Actually, nothing you do matters.
Never have passion or try to get
anything done cuz nothing you do
matters. Just be black-pilled, be this
fat drunk loser making videos where you
make no arguments on your Saturday
night, your Sunday night. Right? If
that's what you want, then keep walking
through the world like nothing you do
matters. Holy [__]
This is all completely removed,
irrelevant internet nonsense with very
little to no real-world impact with
exception to maybe whatever doxxing
occurred, which as far as I can tell no
real-world impact has happened actually
at all in the wake of most of if not any
or if not all of this doxing. But on top
of that
Uh obvious corollary of people not
talking about By the way, not implying
anything with this, but an obvious
corollary of not talking about your doxx
would be not talking about any attempts
on any of your stuff that would have
been done with a doxx, right? So, you
would never know this. You
You can just
>> And again, I'll just reiterate that is
not implying anything happened. I'm not
implying that. You just wouldn't talk
about it, obviously. Pull the plug.
You can pull THE PLUG AND IT GOES AWAY.
IT GOES AWAY. LIKE YOU UNPLUG YOUR
COMPUTER and then magically,
mysteriously,
all the drama just ends. Okay? Like holy
sh
What are the odds? Oh my god. Whoa.
Okay, I'm just so tired of this EHD
drama. People are acting like this is on
par with a exercise meteor flying
through our atmosphere. They act like
this is some world-ending
end of the world nonsense. And what
sucks about this
How could you possibly be upset about
Destiny getting reported for doxxing and
not lose your
mind at this disgusting spineless
fantastic [__] Ethan Klein, suing
people for their content and their
criticisms? How in the world could you
hold these two ideas in your head at the
same time? So funny, man. Dude, it's
>> [laughter]
>> It's It's just like he's just not
thought through anything. It's like so
pathetic, bro. It's like legit like
single-celled organism like pure just,
you know, stimuli
just dr- dragging him around. He's
literally there is no processing power
there.
Uh and what really makes me angry is I
defended all of these people when I was
talking to Steel 2000 in my debate.
There's a video coming up on that soon.
I defended all these people saying
snarkers are important to keeping large
content creators
in check. And the reality is I stand by
Yes, we all agree.
>> that take.
But when you take it this far, when
you're going to the point of creating an
entire Discord server dedicated
dedicated to monitoring
every little time
a person streams or every single fart
that they make on a Tuesday, right? It's
weird.
>> person I've been to is Transfirebat.
That is the absolute That is the only
person who has ever who has ever
documented this to that extent.
Nothing to do with any content creator
in there. None of the content creators
wanted that. It was like one content
creator and a bunch of losers cuz
they're obsessed with that and no one
else wanted it. [laughter] Everyone else
wanted it gone.
You'll look weird to the average person.
You're you're going to look like a
freak, okay? That's That's another thing
about when you try to frame this whole
thing as like some op that's meant to
affect politics. It's like, "Dude, I
said it's like, "Yes, we need to stop
talking about Transfirebat. Stop talking
about Transfirebat. Please stop talking
about Transfirebat. I'm sick of Use the
archive button for something other than
Transfirebat, please.
>> [laughter]
>> You've been six hot streams and we've
got all these Transfirebat streams. What
the [__] is going on?" I'm just laughing
that like Destiny didn't make the top
three. No political content creator made
the like true political content creator
made the top three most talked about. It
was Ethan Klein, Nick Diiorio, then
Transfirebat. It's just like, "Yes,
Hasan [__] directly is telling us that
in order for him to overthrow democracy
and bring about the communist utopia, we
have to keep Transfirebat down. [__]
with Transfirebat. Transfirebat must be
stopped. He They will bring about the
the
Sorry, they will maintain liberalism.
The liberal world order cannot fall so
long as Transfirebat is able to grow,
okay? That's what they needed. I've got
eight months of their Discord logs and
like three months of them are like
totally incomprehensible NONSENSE ABOUT
JUST
>> [laughter]
>> DUDE, I CAN'T WAIT TILL DAN ASKED THAT
ON A STREAM at some point. What the [__]
is a bus ball?
>> [laughter]
>> That's just That's just the reality.
You're going to look like a parasocial
freak.
Okay, I don't know why any of you did
that. It is just so dumb.
Like
>> [laughter]
>> Like I don't get it. I refuse to
understand. Anyway, I would like to say
thank you to all of my patron
supporters. These people are all
enabling this guy. He is dumb. These
people suck.
Okay.
All right.